[Music]
all right boy do we have some artificial
intelligence to talk about today hey
what is up guys mkbhd here and yesterday
was the day one keynote the main keynote
of google i o 2018 and they always go
hard with software there and this year
was no exception so we got all kinds of
great announcements new android p
features especially the interesting new
gesture navigation which will be
interesting to play around with pretty
shortly new google news stuff new google
maps features android dashboard all this
great stuff and in the middle of all
that we got one of the most interesting
new announcements it went by it was kind
of early if you tuned in late you might
have missed it maybe you were just
tuning in to find out what android p
would be called
we still don't know but they shared a
behavior in there called google duplex
and it's a behavior inside of google
assistant that they're still working on
it's a long way from being finished or
from us ever using it so it's maybe a
couple years from that but that's what
it's called so you know how they're
always adding new new features to google
assistant to make your life easier you
know new reminders new routines new
predictive things new things it does to
help you out google duplex
will make it so that you never have to
call
a service business ever again so let's
say i want to get a haircut next monday
at around noon
and this is at a place that doesn't do
online reservations so you have to call
in to make your reservation and you're
not really into that so what you want to
do is ask google assistant hey assistant
make an appointment for my haircut next
monday around noon
and it will actually
call that hair salon
pretend to be a human
talk to the person that picks up
and gets you a reservation for that hair
appointment at around noon
this is what it sounds like
[Music]
so happening out there
hi i'm calling to book a women's haircut
for our clients um i'm looking for
something on may 3rd
store give me one second
or what time are you looking for around
at 12 p.m
we do not have a 12 pm available the
closest we have to that is a 1 15.
do you have anything between 10 am and
uh 12 pm
depending on what service she would like
what service is she looking for
just a woman's haircut for now
okay we have a 10 o'clock
10 am is fine
okay what's her first name
the first name is lisa
okay perfect so i will see lisa at 10
o'clock on may 3rd
okay great thanks great have a great day
bye
what did i just
did
that was
actually amazing did google assistant
just pass the turing test
did that just i think it literally just
did that was a that was a real
conversation with a real person at a
real salon
that is
both amazing and kind of terrifying it
also makes siri look really bad it had
all the right inflections and pauses and
just the intonation the way it talks
was very convincing like i don't know if
i was on the other end of that phone and
i got that phone call i don't know that
i would think
that that was a robot if i wasn't told
ahead of time i
pretty sure i would have been convinced
that's a human um i'm looking for
something on may 3rd it's so human
it's so human especially the way it
responds to those questions like
i mean i guess that lady could have
asked anything but it's very tunneled in
on making that appointment and it was
just uncanny they did another demo on
stage as well
hi um i'd like to reserve a table for
wednesday v7 okay wait pause right there
that um
in that sentence that little pause the
um
it didn't have to do that um
but it did hi um i'd like to reserve a
table for wednesday v7 they're using
that um that little pause specifically
to mimic a human like that google
programmed it they told it to to make
those sounds to convince the person that
they're talking to to believe that
they're speaking on the phone with a
human and the rest of that call went
great too it has some more challenging
things it was dealing with an accent
some unusual questions they had to
respond to but it nailed it for seven
people
um it's for four people
four people when
[Music]
today
wednesday at 6 pm
oh actually we literally for like upper
like five people for four people you can
come
how long is the weight usually to uh be
seated
when tomorrow or weekday or
for next wednesday uh the seven
oh no it's not too busy you you can
count for four people okay
oh i gotcha
thanks oh my gosh i like that guy's
reaction to at the end he's like i don't
know if i just witnessed the scariest or
most amazing thing that i've ever seen
so there's that on stage and there's
also a bunch more examples in a blog
post that google's posted i'll drop a
link below the like button where there's
a bunch more scenarios of things that
they've gotten it to successfully
navigate through in this human
conversation so that just brings me back
to how i feel about it a whole day later
and really from what i've seen there's
there's two main sides to this number
one is the incredible technical
achievement of google
with the machine learning and the
artificial intelligence and the natural
language processing and all of that this
is the culmination of all of their years
of listening to our voices to make
duplex this good it really is something
special in 2018. like we've all gotten
those those robocalls that are obviously
fake right they're like hi i'm i'm karen
want to go on a cruise like you ask it
one question and it immediately falls
apart like
this
seems like it it'll legitimately make
people's lives easier but then the whole
other side of it and it's actually
bigger than i initially was thinking is
should we be worried about this so i've
seen a lot of reactions to this lately
on twitter especially and in some videos
of people saying this is a terrible idea
like this is why would google do this
tricking somebody into thinking they're
talking to a human when they're not that
is deeply concerning and i understand a
lot of it even though i'm mostly on the
side of this particular feature being
particularly helpful but like if i
worked in service i think i would still
want to know if when i'm not speaking to
a human you know what i mean like i
don't have any logical reason why it
doesn't even really matter on my end
but it just the question is does google
have an obligation to let that person
know that they're not speaking to a
human
didn't have any like that stylist
clearly didn't know that they were
speaking to a robot i think a lot of
people say yes you gotta tell them you
gotta immediately let them know that
it's a robot but on the other hand if
you're if you're coming from google's
point of view you have to mimic a human
as closely as possible to make it work
if you want to actually get the person
on the call to pick up and respond to
you and book that appointment they're
listening to humans all day they're
talking to people on the phone if they
get a call that just says hi i'm a
google assistant like they're not gonna
they're probably gonna hang up they're
not gonna wanna answer that so you
actually have to blend in and make it as
seamless as possible for google to do
their job and the assistant to actually
assist you it's just weird from our end
that you know all the the ums and the
pauses and sounding so human-like when
it's not is just uncanny so i know it's
not it's not full open-ended ai it's not
that creepy like pseudo-human
robo status like it hasn't gotten quite
there yet it has a very specific goal
that it has to tunnel in on but i guess
it's interesting that basically you can
see these goal posts getting wider like
back in the day we used to just say look
i just want the assistant to tell me
what the weather is tomorrow and just be
like as human as possible so you'd say
hey google do i need a jacket tomorrow
you get your answer now the goal post is
look i want the assistant to just make a
hair appointment for me on monday i
don't really have the time to call i'm
gonna go get on the train to work
just make that appointment for me
and now it's gonna start doing that but
then next the goal post is gonna be what
like i wanted to edit my youtube videos
for me i wanted to run a company i
wanted to drive me to work
how far does it go i guess that's really
my question at the end of this how far
does it go i had this conversation
briefly with neil degrasse tyson
actually in a video i'll link that below
it's pretty sweet i would love to have
this conversation with elon musk he
talks about this kind of stuff all the
time hitting me up elon but for real
it's like one of those ai versus machine
learning things where it kind of starts
in a box and it's really convincing and
excellent and useful in this box but you
got to keep it in that box but my final
thoughts on google duplex are this
i don't know if people care that they're
talking to a robot i think there's going
to be people on both sides of the
spectrum
but i feel like it wouldn't be that bad
if you know right off the bat you're
talking to a robot like when i when i
trigger the assistant on my phone or on
siri or on alexa or any of those and it
responds like a human i know it's a
robot still like it can be as seamless
and human-like as possible in the voice
and the dictation but it's because i'm
triggering it myself in my phone i know
it's a robot but when you get a phone
call and you answer the phone call that
gets weird because you think you're
answering and talking to a human and
then you might like find out during that
that you're actually talking to a robot
and then you were fooled and then it
then it feels weird then it feels creepy
so that brings us to number two which is
just how far does it go i always wonder
what are we willing to do with robots
that's a weird question but really how
far are we gonna go with these these
robot assistants in our lives
google duplex really triggering the
intense questions out here i'll hang out
in the comments section below it's
open-ended feel free to let me know what
you guys think but until the next one
thanks for watching talk to you later
peace